welcome to hunt library our largest
library on campus
I'm library is home to 600 thousand
volumes private and group study areas in
addition to a fine arts collection as
you can see the facade of the library is
different from the other buildings on
campus this is because it was a gift
from mr. and mrs. Roy hunt and there
were a few stipulations that were given
to the University
number one it must be built out of all
glass and aluminum and number two
nothing could be built in between the
library and Forbes Avenue for up to 50
years there's no better place to take an
afternoon nap than on the first floor of
hunt library I'm sitting in an energy
pod in our group study area right beside
the Maggie Murphy cafe it was created by
a Carnegie Mellon alumnus to keep
external sounds out and internal thumbs
in